cat you think it's unfair uh and mean to
make these jokes do you think Donald
Trump is on to something that it's
basically kicking a man when he's
literally down
[Laughter]
I'm up with that
it was good thank you
I mean I I wrote an entire book about
how it's okay to joke about anything did
you know how's it doing he's doing very
well yes it's doing very well yes and uh
but here's the thing I think actually
you kind of alluded to this what Trump
is doing is way more Savage than any
joke about it because he's basically
saying no you can't make fun of it
because this is a very serious sick
situation yes like have you ever been in
a fight with somebody like a verbal
fight with somebody and you you know
what's the meanest thing they can do
rather than something they can say mean
back is like you're being so crazy I'm
not even talking to you right now
like that like now I am filled with the
rage for weeks
um because he's that's ultimately it is
ultimately the more Savage thing and
imagine if he continued this to be like
no I can't I can't even engage because
he's not well yes no I'm a debate on the
debate stage I don't feel right I'm
sorry that did you guys all saw this sir
are you okay
like do you need anything because I can
tell something's really wrong yes and
maybe you should go to bed and call me
in the morning
nothing Savage nothing is crueler yeah
and more Savage than that yeah he it's
like and nothing is as important as your
health not even this debate I think we
should just not have enough or no the
meanest thing someone I'm worried about
you go yourself
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else